Fertig zum Abtauchen?
Eine Bibliothek mit
Lesesessel – allerdings unter Wasser.
Der Künstler nennt es „Taucherparadies“.
Foto und Motiv sind von Frank Kunert.
Das ist im Grunde so die Idee,
dass man abtauchen kann
in eine andere Welt.
Also auch ein bisschen weg von
den Problemen,  ja?
Es ist einfach so 'ne Oase der Ruhe.
Dieses Modell hier diente als Vorlage
für das Foto „Kletterurlaub“
– eine Anspielung auf geschönte
Urlaubsversprechen in Reisemagazinen.
Man schafft Illusionen im Studio,
[und] die dann
eigentlich so wirken, als sei es echt.
Und das find' ich immer wieder spannend
und das ist ja auch dann ein Spiel
mit der Wirklichkeit.
Frank Kunerts kleine Welten –
in Bildern festgehalten
– mal komisch, mal makaber,
oft grotesk und skurril.
Dieses Bild nennt er „ Fahrt ins Blaue“:
Ausgang offen.
Im Bild „Abwärts“ kritisiert er
Problemverdränger,
die den Abgrund nicht sehen wollen.
Ich möchte so die ganze Palette zeigen
des Lebens von der Tragödie bis zur Komödie,
dass eigentlich alles zusammengehört.
Bevor er zum Fotoapparat greift,
baut er Modelle seiner Motive im Atelier.
Ob Bett, Waschbecken oder Topf –
jedes kleinste Detail ist wichtig.
Viele Miniaturartikel findet er online.
Außerdem verwendet er für den Modellbau
Knete, Spezialwerkzeug,
Leichtschaumplatten und Farbe.
Für besondere Anlässe
kommen auch Spritzen zum Einsatz.
Eine Flasche Rotwein soll den Einzug
in dieses Apartment erleichtern.
Wahrscheinlich steht in der
Immobilienanzeige so
„vollmöbliertes Ein-Zimmer-Apartment“,
und wenn der Interessent dann ankommt,
dann erlebt er sein blaues Wunder.
Inspiration holt sich Frank Kunert
in der realen Welt.
Er lebt im westdeutschen Boppard
am Rhein.
Unterwegs interessiert ihn weniger
das Schöne – viel mehr alles,
an dem die Zeit ihre Spuren
hinterlassen hat.
1963 in Frankfurt am Main geboren
absolviert er nach dem Abitur
eine Ausbildung zum Fotografen.
Nach ersten Stationen als Werbefotograf
beginnt er Mitte der 1990er-Jahre
mit seinen kleinen Welten,
wie er sie nennt.
Die Ideen kommen eigentlich durch den Alltag
und das mischt sich dann mit Eindrücken,
die ich irgendwo sammel, wie zum Beispiel
jetzt auch so Vergänglichkeit,
die man so in den Spuren
von Häusern sieht.
Also, dass da schon Leben
stattgefunden hat, und das
versuche ich dann eben
in meine Bilder zu bringen.
Schnelllebigkeit, Alltag und die Menschen
mit ihren Sorgen und Träumen
sind seine Themen.
Diese Autobahnbrücke hat ihn zu seinem
Foto „Unter der Brücke“ inspiriert.
Nach der ersten Idee skizzierte er,
wie das Modell aussehen könnte.
Also, wir sind hier an meiner
Lieblingsautobahnbrücke
und hier komme ich öfter mal lang
und mir kam die Idee,
da es ja in ganz Deutschland
Wohnraummangel
gerade in den Ballungszentren gibt:
Wie wäre es,
wenn man in den Brückenpfeilern
in die Mitte ein kleines Häuschen baut?
Das ist sozusagen ein „tiny house“,
was ja  im Moment so voll im Trend ist,
und dann wäre doch so einiges
an Problemen gelöst.
Zurück im Atelier arbeitet der 54-Jährige an
seiner Lösung für den Wohnraummangel.
Zwischen zwei Wochen und drei Monaten
investiert Frank Kunert
in seine detaillierten Modelle,
alle im Maßstab 1:20.
Also manchmal frage ich mich auch,
warum mache ich mir so viel Arbeit?
Man könnte das ja auch viel einfacher
haben mit Photoshop,
aber ich glaube, es ist der Weg,
es ist der Weg auch,
die Dinge in die Hand zu nehmen,
ihnen Leben zu geben.
Ist das Motiv fertig, wird es fotografiert -
analog mit einer rund
30 Jahre alten Großformatkamera.
So entstehen Fotografien mit
herausragender Qualität.
Auf Bildbearbeitung verzichtet er.
Das Ergebnis veröffentlicht
Frank Kunert in Bildbänden.
Sein aktuelles  Buch „Lifestyle“
ist nach „Wunderland“
und „Verkehrte Welt“ das dritte
Werk des Künstlers.
Es ist wie eine Bühne, die dann durch den
Betrachter mit seiner Phantasie bespielt
werden kann, und das finde ich reizvoller,
als wenn jetzt noch irgendwie zusätzlich
Personen drin wären.
Obwohl in seinen Bildern niemals
Menschen auftauchen:
Beim Betrachten spürt man
ihre Präsenz deutlich.
Frank Kunerts kleine Geschichten bieten
viel Raum zum Nachdenken.